this is a Fox News Alert good evening
I'm Bret Baier and Washington as people
here in the nation's capital and all
over the country finally get to see the
just Declassified memo alleging FBI
abuses in surveillance practices we have
complete reporting and reaction and as
Dana mentioned a live exclusive
interview with House Intelligence
Committee Chairman Devin Nunez the man
who put together the document and fought
to release it President Trump calls the
findings in this memo a disgrace fellow
Republicans say it shows high level
politicization of the justice process
Democrats and many in law enforcement
say it is damaging inaccurate and out of
context we Fox team coverage tonight
John Roberts is at the White House with
what the administration is saying and
doing about the memo but we begin with
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge here in Washington
the first journalist to get excerpts of
the memo to tell us what's in it well
thank you Bret the White House sent a
letter to the House Intelligence
Committee today confirming the president
used his authority as commander-in-chief
to fully declassify the records without
changes or redactions the memo paints a
troubling picture the newly declassified
four-page Republican staff memo makes
the case but the secret national
security court was kept in the dark by
the FBI and Justice Department when they
sought and secured a surveillance
warrant for Trump campaign aide Carter
page the memo says the court was never
told the former British spy who was paid
by Democrats to put together the Trump
dossier had a personal animus toward the
presidential nominee in September 2016
Christopher Steele admitted to Justice
Department official Bruce or his
feelings against the then candidate
Trump when Steele said he quote was
desperate that Donald Trump would not
get elected and was passionate about him
not being president or was recently
demoted over his contacts with Steele
and Glenn Simpson whose opposition
research firm Fuzion GPS directed the
Trump Project bank records obtained by
the House committees show ORS wife
Nellie worked for fusion GPS and began
investigating Trump as early as May 2016
Republican investigators said the court
was also never told about the dossiers
political roots
neither the initial FISA application in
October 2016
or any of the renewals disclosed a
reference the role of the DNC Clinton
campaign or any party campaign in
funding Steele's efforts even though the
political origins of the steel dossier
were then known to senior DOJ and FBI
officials according to the memo Deputy
FBI director Andrew McCabe testified
before the committee in December 2017
that no surveillance warrant would have
been sought without the steeled dossier
information McCabe was removed earlier
this week British Court records show
fusion gps directed steel to quietly
brief a half dozen American media
outlets in the fall of 2016 but the
majority did not go with the story but
one who did was apparently used to
justify FBI surveillance the Carter page
FISA application also cited extensively
a September 23rd 2016 Yahoo News article
by Michael Isikoff which focuses on
pages July 2016 trip to Moscow in a Fox
interview last spring Paige denied
working with the Russians I have never
broken any law or done anything untoward
in Russia or relating to any Russian
person according to the memo an FBI
counterintelligence chief said the
corroboration of the steeled dossier was
in the early stages even as the initial
page FISA application was submitted days
before the inauguration Comey later
testified he told the president-elect at
Trump Tower the dossier was quote
salacious and unverified but strikingly
that dossier was used repeatedly to
renew the surveillance of page by Comey
his deputy mccabe then obama Deputy
Attorney General Sally Yates and later
by Trump appointee Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein in the memo
Republicans raised the specter of
legality over the handling of the Trump
dossier and representations made to the
FISA Court today the Attorney General
sent a formal referral to the inspector
general for investigation break all
right Catherine thank you